Ladies and gentlemen, public radio listeners everywhere, now let us praise famous crap, OK, and not so famous crap too.
女士们先生们，世界各地的公共广播听众们，现在让我们来赞美一下那些著名的垃圾，好吗？当然，还有那些不太出名的垃圾。
Well, there's a show called Boy Meets World . You ever seen it?
嗯，有个节目叫《男孩遇见世界》。你看过吗？
No.
没有。
It's great. It's so good.
它很棒。真的非常好。
It's in syndication?
它在重播吗？
Yeah, it's one of those shows that just went under the radar.
是的，它就是那种被忽视的节目之一。
Friends, we are not here today to talk about those supposedly good TV programs people who think that they're smart like to talk about when they talk about TV. We're here to talk about the stuff that makes up so much of TV. We're here to speak of reruns. And not good reruns at that, I'm talking your Matlock s, your Living Singles , your Kate & Allies . This voice you are hearing is Starlee Kine, one of the producers of our radio program. And I asked her to talk about her relationship to TV, because she's the first person I've ever met who actively prefers reruns like Boy Meets World .
朋友们，我们今天不是来谈论那些自以为聪明的人在谈论电视时喜欢谈论的所谓好节目的。我们是来谈论那些构成电视大部分内容的节目的。我们是来谈论重播的。而且还不是那种好的重播，我说的是《马特洛克》、《独身生活》、《凯特与艾莉》这类。你听到的这个声音是斯塔莉·凯恩，我们广播节目的制作人之一。我请她谈谈她与电视的关系，因为她是我认识的第一个主动偏爱《男孩遇见世界》这类重播节目的人。
And it just like was on for years, but you never knew it. And now it's just like permanently in reruns, and it's on like four different channels. But it's not very good.
它播了好几年，但你根本不知道。现在它就像永久处于重播状态，在四个不同的频道播出。但它其实并不怎么好看。
In fact, is it actually bad?
事实上，它真的很烂吗？
I think so. I mean, it's hard for me to tell at this point, but it's bad, yeah.
我想是吧。我是说，现在我很难分辨，但它确实很烂。
So if it's bad, why are you watching?
既然很烂，你为什么还要看？
It's very, very, very comforting to watch it.
看它非常、非常、非常令人舒心。
It's comforting because you used to watch it when you were a little kid?
令人舒心是因为你小时候经常看它？
No.
不。
You never saw it as a kid?
你小时候从没看过？
No, not that one. But Boy Meets World , it's like it didn't even matter that I didn't watch it as a little kid. I can imagine little kids being in really comfortable, carpeted family rooms and laying with their elbows propped up and watching Boy Meets World and feeling really safe. Because it's like the safest thing in the world. This family is so nuclear, it's perfect. But it's soundstages, and it looks really fake. The principal is also the kid's neighbor. You know what I mean? He's just always there and always looking after everyone.
没有，没看过那部。但《男孩遇见世界》，我小时候没看过也无所谓。我可以想象小孩子们在非常舒适、铺着地毯的家庭房里，胳膊肘支着躺在那儿，看着《男孩遇见世界》，感觉非常安全。因为它就像世界上最安全的东西。这个家庭非常核心，非常完美。但那是摄影棚布景，看起来真的很假。校长还是那个孩子的邻居。你明白我的意思吗？他总是出现在那里，总是照顾每个人。
Hey son, how was your day?
嘿，儿子，你今天过得怎么样？
Fine.
挺好。
What did you do in school?
你在学校做什么了？
Nothing.
什么都没做。
Hey, hold on right there. You know, every day I ask you, what did you do. And every day you tell me, nothing. Well, I'm tired of nothing. I mean, we both know something happened today. And I want to know what it is.
嘿，等一下。你知道，我每天都问你做了什么。而你每天都告诉我，什么都没做。好吧，我厌倦了“什么都没做”。我是说，我们都知道今天发生了什么事。我想知道那是什么。
I decided to be a girl.
我决定当个女孩。
I would imagine, if I were a little kid watching it, I'd feel so secure. Knowing that there's kids out there who feel secure is enough for me to feel comforted by it and watch it every time its on.
我想，如果我是个看这部剧的小孩，我会感到很安心。知道外面有孩子感到安心，这就足以让我感到慰藉，并且每次它播出时我都会看。
I try very hard to establish these things so that I have these reruns, because I live in eternal fear that the reruns are going to be gone. Like last night, I was watching TV and I couldn't find a rerun anywhere and I was panicking. The Godfather was on, and I was flipping, flipping, and I couldn't find one. I was just like, how is this possible? There was a rerun though. It was a rerun of The Nanny was on. And I don't have any relationship with it, so I was stuck.
我非常努力地确立这些东西，这样我才有这些重播节目可以看，因为我一直生活在一种永恒的恐惧中，担心重播会消失。就像昨晚，我正在看电视，到处都找不到重播节目，我感到很恐慌。《教父》正在播出，我换来换去，一个重播都找不到。我当时想，这怎么可能？不过还是有一个重播。那是《保姆》的重播。我和它没有任何共鸣，所以我被卡住了。
Because she's so scared of that happening, Starlee is perpetually cultivating new reruns, forcing yourself to immerse in them. Her latest is Caroline in the City .
因为她太害怕那种情况发生，斯塔莉一直在不断培养新的重播节目，强迫自己沉浸其中。她最近看的是《卡罗琳在城市》。
When I watch Caroline in the City , it's like I'm really trying to find something, even though I hate it so much, so much. I hate it, every part of it. Hate the way she draws. I hate the way she talks. I hate her assistant, everything.
当我看《卡罗琳在城市》时，就像我真的在努力寻找什么，尽管我非常非常讨厌它。我讨厌它，它的每一个部分。讨厌她画画的方式。讨厌她说话的方式。讨厌她的助手，一切都讨厌。
And as you've watched Caroline in the City over the course of weeks, do you now actually like it?
随着过去几周你一直看《卡罗琳在城市》，你现在真的喜欢它了吗？
I don't like it. But I know it. I am very familiar with it.
我不喜欢它。但我了解它。我非常熟悉它。
And that's enough?
那这就够了吗？
That's enough.
这就够了。
What percentage of television is about just straight up comfort and what percentage is about what we think of, traditionally, as entertainment?
电视节目中有多大比例纯粹是为了慰藉，有多大比例是我们传统意义上认为的娱乐？
For me? Oh God, 80% is about comfort for me. If something good gets in there it's an accident. Or it's because I feel obligated to watch something good, because I know people are going to ask me the next day.
对我来说？天哪，对我来说80%是为了慰藉。如果中间掺杂了什么好东西，那纯属偶然。或者是因为我觉得有义务看点好东西，因为我知道第二天会有人问我。
Well, today on our radio program, a defense of not going out into the world and looking for new experiences, a defense of dwelling on what you already know, a defense of staying caught in your own personal reruns. Stories of people who have the same thing going on with some story from their own past that Starlee has with Caroline in the City and Boy Meets World .
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要为不走向世界、不寻求新体验进行辩护，为沉湎于已知事物进行辩护，为保持在个人重播中进行辩护。我们要讲一些人的故事，他们对自己过去的故事有着和斯塔莉对《卡罗琳在城市》和《男孩遇见世界》一样的执念。
From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in three, yes three, acts. Act One-- Action! Action! Action! In that act the story of what happens when a person, who actually has the power to create reruns, gets stuck in a rerun. Act Two-- Marriage As Rerun. In that act, an exploration, possibly, we think, the first ever, of how in every couple, in every marriage, we are stuck hearing the same stories from our partners over and over, and what we're supposed to think of that. Act Three-- Reruns At The Back Of The Bus. In that act, Sarah Vowell explains what happens when we, as a nation, keep telling ourselves the same political fable over and over long past the point where it makes any sense to. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，是美国公共广播国际公司发行的《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三幕，没错，三幕。第一幕——动作！动作！动作！在这一幕里，讲述的是当一个真正有能力创作重播内容的人，自己却陷入重播时会发生什么。第二幕——婚姻如重播。在这一幕里，我们可能第一次探索了每一对夫妻、每一段婚姻中，我们是如何被迫一遍又一遍地听伴侣讲同样的故事，以及我们该如何看待这一点。第三幕——车尾的重播。在这一幕里，莎拉·沃威尔解释了当我们作为一个国家，不断地对自己重复同样的政治寓言，直到它毫无意义时会发生什么。请继续收听。
Act One-- Action! Action! Action! Well, Starlee Kine, who you just met, somebody who loves reruns more than anyone who I've ever known, came upon a rerun moment. An entire film caught in a rerun in a way that dumbfounded even her. The film is called The Beaver Trilogy , and she put together this story about it.
第一幕——动作！动作！动作！好吧，斯塔莉·凯恩，你们刚刚见过，她比我认识的任何人都更爱重播节目，她遇到了一个重播时刻。整部电影以一种连她自己都目瞪口呆的方式陷入了重播。这部电影叫《海狸三部曲》，她为此整理了这个故事。
10 minutes into watching The Beaver Trilogy I could already feel how much I'd be talking about it. Once it was over, I felt mournful that I'd never be able to see it again for the first time. Everything about it is so surprising and unexpected, the way movies almost never are. And what  I'm going to try to do right now, here on the radio, is to recreate for you what it's like to see it.
在看了10分钟《海狸三部曲》后，我就已经感觉到我会为此谈论多久了。一旦结束，我感到很难过，因为我再也没法第一次看到它了。关于它的一切都那么令人惊讶和意想不到，电影几乎从来不是这样的。我现在要尝试做的，就是在广播里，为你还原看到它是什么感觉。
Are you typing it? Oh, wow. When can I see this?
你在打字吗？哦，哇。我什么时候能看到这个？
It's starts with a hand held camera moving up to a kid in the middle of an empty parking lot. The kid's taking pictures of a parked TV news traffic helicopter. He realizes he's being filmed, and starts into a John Wayne impersonation.
它以一个手持摄像机开始，镜头移向一个站在空旷停车场中间的孩子。那孩子正在拍摄一架停着的电视新闻交通直升机。他意识到自己被拍了，就开始模仿约翰·韦恩。
John Wayne? Here. Mom. Here is John Wayne. Yo, while I'll tell ya something out there in TV land, I'm hamming it up. I'll tell you.
约翰·韦恩？在这里。妈。这里是约翰·韦恩。嘿，虽然我要告诉电视机前的各位，我是在演戏。我告诉你们。
The kid's wearing '70s clothes, bell-bottom jeans and a shirt with racing stripes. He has a Casio watch on. He looks to be in his early 20s. He cycles through a couple more impersonations, Barry Manilow, Rocky Balboa.
那孩子穿着70年代的衣服，喇叭裤和一件带有赛车条纹的衬衫。他戴着一块卡西欧手表。他看起来20岁出头。他又循环了几次模仿，巴里·马尼洛、洛奇·巴尔博亚。
He's a good guy, you know. He knows his fight. He knows his left from his right. He knows his left toe from his right toe, you know. He's a good guy, and he loves his wife, Adrian, you know. So, anyway. I love it up here though. I was just taking some pictures of Sky two over there, and man, it's really fantastic out here. I love it. I love it up here. I love impersonating and, by gosh, if I made the tube, I just thank you so much. I really do. So, boy I can't believe this. This is actual live, huh?
他是个好人，你知道的。他知道自己的战斗。他分得清左右。他分得清左脚趾和右脚趾，你知道的。他是个好人，而且他爱他的妻子阿德里安，你知道的。所以，不管怎样。不过我喜欢在这里。我刚才只是在拍那边的“天空2号”，天哪，这里真是太棒了。我喜欢。我喜欢在这里。我喜欢模仿，天哪，如果我上了电视，我真的非常感谢。我真的非常感谢。所以，天哪，我简直不敢相信。这是真实的直播，对吧？
Well, it's not going out yet, but it will.
嗯，还没播出，但很快就会了。
Well, I'd like to get a picture of you. That would be great.
嗯，我想拍张你的照片。那会很棒的。
Take a picture of me taking a picture?
拍一张我拍照的照片？
Well, would that be all right?
嗯，那样可以吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK, smile, you're on Candid Camera .
好，笑一笑，你在《隐藏的摄像机》里了。
Don't you love this kid? You love him, but you don't know why you love him, right?
你不喜欢这个孩子吗？你喜欢他，但你不知道为什么喜欢他，对吧？
Well, my day has come. It's shining.
好吧，我的日子终于来了。它在闪耀。
When I saw this in the theater, I couldn't get over what a great idea he was. I loved that someone thought up a character his is so excited just to be taking pictures of a news helicopter parked on a strip of highway. It's only later, after the movie was over, that I learned that I wasn't watching a feature film at all. It's a documentary shot in 1979. This kid's real.
当我在电影院看到这个时，我对他的伟大创意赞叹不已。我喜欢有人想出一个角色，仅仅因为拍了一架停在公路旁的直升机就如此兴奋。直到电影结束后，我才知道我看的根本不是故事片。这是一部1979年拍摄的纪录片。这孩子是真实的。
Basically, what happened is I was working at a television station in Salt Lake City, and they had a new gadget called a video camera. And I walked out into the parking lot to test out a camera.
基本上，发生的事情是我在盐湖城的一家电视台工作，他们有一个叫摄像机的新玩意儿。我走到停车场去测试摄像机。
This is Trent Harris, the film's director.
这就是特伦特·哈里斯，这部电影的导演。
And saw this fellow, and he sort of walked up to me, and away he went. It took 30 seconds, and I was so enthralled with him that I knew that I just had to keep filming him.
我看到了这个家伙，他径直朝我走来，然后就说了起来。只花了30秒，我就被他迷住了，我知道我必须一直拍他。
It's my little car. My little '64 Chevy. Hang on, let me kind of straighten it up before I get on the tube.
这是我的小车。我的那辆64年的雪佛兰。等一下，在我上电视前让我先整理一下。
And then he's so excited, he just keeps going, rambling, rambling, rambling.
然后他太兴奋了，就一直说，喋喋不休，喋喋不休。
Is that where your from, Beaver?
你是从那儿来的吗，比弗？
Yeah, I'm from Beaver.
是啊，我来自比弗。
Beaver is a small kind of farming town. It's not close to anything really.
比弗是一个小小的农业城镇。其实离什么地方都不近。
What goes on in Beaver? It's just kind of a town where you drag main at night, go to school in the daytime. I'm not in school now, but I used to be. I'm 21 now so. Just kind of out working for the Union Pacific Railroad.
比弗有什么好玩的？那只是个晚上可以在主街漫步，白天去上学的小镇。我现在没上学，但我以前上过。我现在21岁。只是在联合太平洋铁路工作。
It turns out that he's driven from Beaver just that very morning. His plan was to go to the news station and try and get on TV. So when Trent approached, it was almost like the Beaver kid had been expecting it.
事实证明，他那天早上刚从比弗开车过来。他的计划是去新闻台，试着上电视。所以当特伦特走近时，简直就像那个比弗男孩一直在等着这一刻。
But I love hamming it up. You can tell. Well, I'm on TV. I can't believe it. Just in the right place at the right time I guess.
但我喜欢表演。你看得出来。嗯，我上电视了。我简直不敢相信。我想我只是在正确的时间出现在了正确的地点。
Part of what makes watching the movie so great is the obvious joy the two of them feel over having found each other. If Trent had wandered out five minutes later, the kid probably would have been heading back home. If the kid had come the next day, Trent wouldn't have been there filming. It was just a lucky accident that they met, and it changed their lives forever.
让这部电影如此伟大的部分原因，是他们两人在找到彼此后感受到的那种明显的快乐。如果特伦特晚走出来五分钟，那孩子可能已经回家了。如果那孩子第二天来，特伦特就不会在那里拍他。他们相遇纯属幸运的巧合，但这彻底改变了他们的一生。
Dear Trent, how's things going up there? I hope OK. I hope I haven't bothered you in any way with the calls that I have made. If I have, I'm sorry, really.
亲爱的特伦特，你在上面过得怎么样？希望一切都好。希望我打来的电话没有打扰到你。如果有的话，我很抱歉，真的。
This is the very next scene. There's an image of somebody holding a handwritten note. You have no idea what's happening. And slowly you realize that it's a letter from the Beaver Kid. He's assembled a talent show, and he wants  Trent to come down and film it.
这是紧接着的一幕。画面中有人拿着一张手写的字条。你根本不知道发生了什么。慢慢地你意识到这是来自比弗男孩的一封信。他组织了一场才艺秀，他想让特伦特去拍下来。
The show is scheduled to come off on the 31st. Please, Trent, come down. I'm begging, I'm pleading. PS, I will be putting on my makeup at the open mortuary at 8:00 AM. You may want to get some shots.
表演定在31号。求求你，特伦特，一定要来。我在乞求你，在哀求你。附注：我会在早上8点在露天停尸房化妆。你可能想拍一些镜头。
Jeez, let's see. How are we going  to do this now?
天哪，让我们看看。现在我们该怎么做呢？
And sure enough, the next shot we're at a mortuary, as if that makes any sense at all. The Beaver Kid sits with his hair clipped back away from his face. The local mortician applies eye shadow, mascara, rouge, and lipstick. I'm guessing, because she's the most qualified person in town to do it, but no one explains. The Kid seems different than he was in the parking lot, way more nervous.
果然，下一个镜头我们就在停尸房了，就好像这有什么逻辑可言似的。比弗男孩坐在那里，头发夹在脑后。当地的殡仪员给他涂上眼影、睫毛膏、胭脂和口红。我猜是因为她是镇上最有资格做这件事的人，但没人解释。那孩子看起来和在停车场时不一样，紧张多了。
Well, Trent, I think I'll go get into my threads.
好了，特伦特，我想我要去穿我的行头了。
The  mortician smiles encouragingly. Let's get you wiggy on, she says.
殡仪员鼓励地笑了笑。我们给你戴上假发吧，她说。
Let's get your wiggy on.
让我们给你戴上假发。
Get my wig on.
戴上我的假发。
And pretty soon he's in character, wearing a bulky leather jacket, tight black jeans, and a blond wig that hangs down to his waist. He's supposed to be Olivia Newton-John.
很快他就进入了角色，穿着厚重的皮夹克，紧身黑牛仔裤，还有一顶垂到腰间的金色假发。他要扮演奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰。
My purse, Olivia. Well, I really don't know what to say now. I guess I ought to get down in a minute. And I'm off.
我的包，奥利维亚。嗯，我现在真的不知道该说什么了。我想我该下去了。我走了。
Watching all this, the thought doesn't occur to you  that the kid's gay or closeted. And I don't think he in fact is. He's more like an overgrown boy dressing up for Halloween, doing the most outrageous thing he can think of. He can barely suppress the giggles as he zips into his knee-high boots. Again, here's Trent.
看着这一切，你根本不会想到这孩子是同性恋或隐瞒了身份。而且我认为他其实也不是。他更像是个在万圣节打扮自己的长不大的男孩，做着他能想到的最荒谬的事情。当他拉上齐膝靴的拉链时，他几乎抑制不住自己的咯咯笑声。再次重申，这是特伦特。
You know, I grew up in a small town too, and I know what it's like to be on the outside. It's very difficult. There's an awful lot of pressure from the school, from the church, from your family, from everything to make you conform. And you just can't go around dressing up like Olivia Newton-John without people getting cranky.
你知道，我也是在一个小镇长大的，我知道被排挤是什么感觉。这非常困难。学校、教堂、家人、一切事物都给你巨大的压力，逼你顺从。你可不能随随便便穿得像奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰一样而不让别人抓狂。
For a decade Joan and  Julie [? Kesser ?] have been singing before audiences throughout Beaver County and the state. They have performed on the Eugene Jelesnik Show.
十年来，琼和朱莉（凯瑟）一直在比弗县和全州各地的观众面前演唱。她们在尤金·杰莱斯尼克秀上表演过。
The next thing you see is a man with a mustache standing on the stage of a school auditorium. He's the Beaver High School vice principal, who the kid has recruited to serve as the talent show MC.
接下来你看到的是一个留着胡子的男人站在学校礼堂的舞台上。他是比弗高中的副校长，这孩子招募他来担任才艺秀的主持人。
Joan and Julie [? Kesser ?] will now sing "The Happiest Girl in the Whole USA."
琼和朱莉（凯瑟）现在将演唱《全美最幸福的女孩》。
[SINGING]
（唱歌）
The whole thing is like this. There's a drill team, a ventriloquist act. It's all pretty much what you expect from a small town talent show until the Beaver Kid comes out.
整个过程都是这样。有仪仗队，有腹语表演。在比弗男孩出场之前，这一切都和你预期的乡镇才艺秀差不多。
Ladies and gentleman, Olivia Newton-Don.
女士们先生们，奥利维亚·纽顿-唐。
[MUSIC PLAYING] [SINGING]
（音乐响起）（唱歌）
It doesn't matter that he can't really sing, or that he looks nothing like Olivia Newton-John. Watching the kid perform is totally riveting. His eyes are closed, and his face looks pained. He's singing directly into the camera.
他是不是真的会唱歌，或者他看起来一点也不像奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰，这都无关紧要。看着这孩子表演完全扣人心弦。他闭着眼睛，脸上带着痛苦的表情。他正对着镜头唱歌。
[SINGING]
（唱歌）
It goes on for a long time. It's so long and so raw that you worry. You feel like maybe you shouldn't be watching. It feels too personal. You have no idea what's going to happen next. And at the same time, you're aware he's orchestrated this whole elaborate event at 11:00 on a Saturday morning to a half-empty theater just so he can be up on stage at this moment and be put on TV. It's like watching someone finally get what they've always needed.
这持续了很长时间。它太长、太原始了，以至于你感到担忧。你会觉得也许你不应该看。这感觉太私人了。你根本不知道接下来会发生什么。与此同时，你意识到他在周六早上11点组织了这场精心策划的活动，在一个半空的剧院里，只是为了让自己能在这一刻登上舞台，出现在电视上。就像看着某人终于得到了他们一直需要的东西。
Soon enough, the screen fades to black. Then something happens I never would have seen coming. A new scene opens. A handheld camera shakily approaches a kid taking pictures in the middle of an empty parking lot.
很快，屏幕淡入黑色。然后发生了一件我从未预料到的事情。新的一幕开始了。手持摄像机晃晃悠悠地接近一个在空旷停车场中间拍照的孩子。
Wow. Are you filming this?
哇。你在拍这个吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
I can't believe it. I can't believe it. I never been on a set before.
我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。我以前从来没上过摄影棚。
Everything's exactly the same. Except this time, instead of the Beaver Kid, it's Sean Penn. Sean Penn.
一切都完全一样。只是这一次，不是比弗男孩，而是肖恩·潘。肖恩·潘。
I'm lucky I came on. I'm an impersonator. I'll do a John Wayne.
我很幸运我来了。我是个模仿者。我会来一段约翰·韦恩。
All right, go ahead.
好吧，请继续。
Well, I'll tell you out there in TV land, I just made extra, and I'm just tickled to death. I love hamming it up, you can tell.
嗯，我会告诉电视机前的各位，我刚拍了加演片段，我真是高兴死了。我喜欢表演，你看得出来。
When you watch the movie, there is no explanation for any of this. You have no idea why it's happening again, this time to one of the most famous actors in the world. But I can explain. Shortly after Trent shot the talent show, he moved out to Hollywood with dreams of making it big. But his first film was an unlikely vehicle to stardom. A virtually plotless single character dramatization of the documentary he'd already made. He wrote out a script and started looking for a leading man.
当你观看这部电影时，对此没有任何解释。你根本不知道为什么这事会再次发生，而且这次是发生在世界上最著名的演员之一身上。但我可以解释。特伦特拍完才艺秀后不久，就怀揣着成名梦搬到了好莱坞。但他的第一部电影并不是通往星途的有利载体。这是一部几乎没有情节、由单一角色演绎他已经拍过的纪录片的电影。他写好了剧本，开始寻找男主角。
It was 1981. Sean Penn had just finished filming Fast Times at Ridgemont High , and within a year he'd be a full-fledged movie star. But when Trent found him, Sean Penn was just another unknown actor looking for work. Once again, Trent lucked out.
那是1981年。肖恩·潘刚拍完《开放的美国学府》，一年内他就会成为真正的电影明星。但特伦特找到他时，肖恩·潘只是另一个等待机会的无名演员。特伦特再次走运了。
Basically, I didn't have any money. I'm shooting this thing with a home video camera. You can't believe some of the people I auditioned for this, Nick Cage, Eric Stoltz, Anthony Edwards.
基本上，我当时没钱。我用家庭摄像机拍这个。你简直无法相信我为这个角色试镜的人，尼古拉斯·凯奇、埃里克·斯托尔兹、安东尼·爱德华兹。
Really?
真的吗？
These people all wanted to play this part. And somebody said, you ought to call this guy, Sean Penn, on the phone. I didn't know who he was. I made him an addition for the role. And he came down to the place I was at, and rather than have him read lines, he decided that what he wanted to do was just become the character. And that he would follow me around for for the rest of the day. So he became my cousin Larry from Idaho. And then he just followed me around that day. And I introduced him to people as my cousin from Idaho named Larry. And he acted the part out. And it was really kind of funny, because a year later people would come up to me and say, boy your cousin's really become a big star.
这些人全都想演这个角色。有人说，你应该给这个叫肖恩·潘的家伙打个电话。我不知道他是谁。我让他为这个角色试镜。他来到我所在的地方，他没有读台词，而是决定他想做的就是直接成为这个角色。他会在剩下的时间里跟着我。所以他成了我来自爱达荷州的表弟拉里。然后他那天就一直跟着我。我把他介绍给大家说是我来自爱达荷州的表弟拉里。他演得很入戏。这真的挺有趣的，因为一年后人们还会走到我面前说，天哪，你的表弟真的成了大明星了。
Let's get your wiggy on.
让我们给你戴上假发。
Let's get my wiggy on, and Olivia will just about be here. Hello, I really don't know quite what to say. I guess we ought to be going.
让我们戴上我的假发，奥利维亚很快就到了。你好，我真的不知道该说什么。我想我们该走了。
It's practically a shot for shot remake.
这几乎是一场镜头对镜头的重拍。
[MUSIC PLAYING] [SINGING]
（音乐响起）（唱歌）
The only difference between this version and the one with the real kid is the ending. After the concert, Sean Penn, whose character's name is Larry, goes home and calls up the director on the phone and asks him not to play the footage on TV. He's worried people will take it the wrong way. The director refuses. Sean Penn drops the phone and picks up a shotgun. He puts the barrel in his mouth and cocks the trigger. [PHONE RINGING] Then the phone rings.
这一版本和真人版唯一的区别在于结局。演出结束后，肖恩·潘（他的角色名叫拉里）回家给导演打了个电话，请求他不要在电视上播出这段录像。他担心人们会误解。导演拒绝了。肖恩·潘放下电话，拿起一把猎枪。他把枪管放进嘴里，扣动了扳机。（电话铃响）接着电话响了。
Yes.
喂。
Hello, Larry? This is Carissa. Listen, I thought your performance at the talent show was really funny. I can hardly wait to see it on TV. Anyway, I'm having a party Saturday night. Would you like to come and act like Olivia?
喂，拉里？我是卡丽莎。听着，我觉得你在才艺秀上的表演真的很有趣。我迫不及待地想在电视上看到它。不管怎样，我周六晚上有个派对。你想来扮演奥利维亚吗？
Sean Penn puts on his Olivia wig, blinks away his tears, and starts singing into a hair brush. It all feels very melodramatic and pat and unbelievable, like a tacked on Hollywood ending. And then the screen goes black. The movie seems to be over. And then, a handheld camera, a parking lot, a kid taking pictures.
肖恩·潘戴上他的奥利维亚假发，眨掉眼泪，开始对着发刷唱歌。这一切感觉非常伤感、陈腐且不可信，就像是一个生硬的好莱坞结局。然后屏幕变黑。电影似乎结束了。然后，一个手持摄像机，一个停车场，一个拍照的孩子。
What, why, are you filming this?
什么，为什么，你在拍这个吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Wow, oh gosh, I've been wanting to get on the  tube so bad.
哇，天哪，我太想上电视了。
Everything's exactly the same. Except this time, instead of a young Sean Penn, it's a young Crispin Glover, Crispin Glover. That's right, the guy that played Michael   J. Fox's dad in Back to the Future .
一切都完全一样。只是这一次，不是年轻的肖恩·潘，而是年轻的克里斯平·格洛弗，克里斯平·格洛弗。没错，就是在《回到未来》里演迈克尔·J·福克斯父亲的那个家伙。
Well, let's see here. Here's a  little bit of the old John Wayne for you. Well, let me tell ya, something out there in TV land. I just made the tube, and it just tickles the heck right out of me.
嗯，让我们看看。这是给你们的一点老约翰·韦恩的表演。好吧，让我告诉你们，电视机前的各位。我刚上了电视，这真是让我高兴得不得了。
The rest is the same too. There's Crispin in the mortuary.
其余的也一样。克里斯平也在停尸房。
Guess I'd better get into my threads.
我想我最好去换上行头。
There's Crispin at the town talent show.
克里斯平也在镇上的才艺秀上。
[SINGING]
（唱歌）
But while the first two versions of the story were basically made with a home video camera and looked it, this one looks like a real movie. It's shot on film. There's lighting and extras and actual sets. It also cost a lot more. Trent spent $50,000 on it. And, as is often the case in Hollywood, the big budget remake is not as good as the original. Trent adds a whole new backstory to make the Beaver Kid seem like an heroic outsider. People are constantly mocking him, sticking tacks on his chair, telling him he'll never make it onto TV. And the director is an oily, villainous, mustachioed type name Terrance. And just like in the Sean Penn version, Crispin pulls out a gun after the talent show and considers killing himself. He calls the director and begs him not to put the footage on TV. [PHONE RINGING]
但是，当故事的前两个版本基本上是用家庭摄像机拍摄并带有家庭录像感时，这一个看起来就像真正的电影。它是胶片拍摄的。有灯光、临时演员和真正的场景。它也花了很多钱。特伦特花了5万美元。而且，就像好莱坞经常发生的那样，大制作的重拍版并没有原版好。特伦特增加了一个全新的背景故事，让比弗男孩看起来像个英雄般的局外人。人们不断嘲笑他，在他的椅子上放图钉，告诉他永远别想上电视。导演是一个油头粉面、留着胡子、名叫特伦斯的恶棍角色。就像肖恩·潘的版本一样，克里斯平在才艺秀后掏出了枪，考虑自杀。他给导演打电话，乞求他不要把录像放上电视。（电话铃响）
Hello?
喂？
Terrance, how ya pal? I hope you don't think I'm crazy for this, but I'm a little worried about that Olivia number. And I'd be willing to pay for your gas, and film and stuff if you just wouldn't put it on TV.
特伦斯，伙计，你怎么样？希望你别觉得我疯了，但我有点担心那个奥利维亚的部分。如果你不把它放上电视，我愿意支付你的油费、胶片费等等。
I put a lot of time and effort into this project. Look, people are going to love it. You look great. And besides, I got a deadline to meet. Would I lie to you?
我在这个项目上花了很多时间和精力。听着，人们会喜欢的。你看起来很棒。再说，我还要赶截止日期。我会骗你吗？
I emerge as a character in this series. And I guess my character is just kind of a jerk, for lack of a better word. He is very insensitive and very, sort of, just after a story and nothing else, and very exploitative.
我成了这个系列里的一个角色。我想我的角色简直就是个混蛋，找不到更好的词来形容。他非常麻木不仁，而且非常、某种程度上、只是为了一个故事而不择手段，非常剥削人。
When I asked Trent why he felt the need to add the phone call, and the gun, and exploitative director character, at first he says, it was just for dramatic effect. He tells me every movie needs a villain. He tells me reality doesn't have anything to do with anything. He tells me to shut up. And then, finally, an hour into our interview, he tells me this.
当我问特伦特为什么觉得有必要加上那个电话、那把枪和那个剥削人的导演角色时，起初他说，那只是为了戏剧效果。他告诉我每部电影都需要一个反派。他告诉我现实和这一切毫无关系。他让我闭嘴。然后，终于，在采访进行了一个小时后，他告诉了我这个。
What happened? I did get a phone call. I did get a phone call after I'd been in Beaver. And the phone call said, listen I've been thinking about that, maybe you shouldn't put it on TV. And I remember saying, oh, don't worry about it. It's going to be fine. And maybe I wasn't as sensitive as I should have been or could have been. Not too long after that, I found out that he'd been shot.
发生了什么？我确实接到了一个电话。我确实在比弗之后接到了一个电话。那个电话说，听着，我一直在想那件事，也许你不应该把它放上电视。我记得我说，哦，别担心。会没事的。也许我当时不够敏感，没有达到我应该或者可以达到的程度。没过多久，我就发现他中枪了。
Trent called the hospital, and was told the Beaver Kid had an accident with a gun. The kid was OK though, able to talk on the phone.
特伦特打电话给医院，得知比弗男孩发生了枪支意外。不过孩子没事，还能在电话里说话。
And then he just kept apologizing to me, which was kind of very confusing. Very sorry that he'd put me through what he was putting me through. Which seemed kind of odd at the time, because I felt like I should be apologizing to him. I guess I felt like maybe I'd pushed him a little bit too much.
然后他就不停地向我道歉，这让我感到非常困惑。很抱歉他经历了我让他经历的一切。这在当时看起来很奇怪，因为我觉得应该是我向他道歉才对。我想我可能觉得我有点太逼他了。
The Beaver Kid declined my request for an interview. After all that, Trent quit his TV job, never airing his footage of the talent show, and drove to Hollywood where he immediately started working on the Sean Penn version of the story. Still thinking about how he'd originally ignored the kid's request not to broadcast the footage and how the kid ended up in the hospital.
比弗男孩拒绝了我的采访请求。在那之后，特伦特辞掉了电视台的工作，从没播出过那段才艺秀的录像，并开车去了好莱坞，在那里他立即开始制作故事的肖恩·潘版本。他依然在想，当初他是如何无视那个孩子不要播出录像的请求，以及那个孩子最终是如何住进医院的。
Do you connect the two things together?
你把这两件事联系在一起了吗？
I mean, in my mind, I connect them together. I don't know whether it's true or not, but in my mind I connect it together. Again, I'm very, very reluctant to talk about what is going on in his mind or to speculate that way. I don't think it's fair.
我是说，在我心里，我把它们联系在一起。我不知道这是不是真的，但在我心里我把它们联系在一起。再说一次，我非常、非常不愿谈论他心里在想什么，或者那样揣测。我觉得这不公平。
I mean, but it seems more about you though. It seems more about--
我是说，但这看起来更像是关于你自己的故事。看起来更像是关于——
If you're asking me, and I think you're trying to, if I feel guilty about anything that has happened? The answer to that is yes. Of course, I do feel guilty about things. I feel guilty about putting myself and my needs above other people's needs, above his needs. I wasn't appreciative of that, and  sensitive of that. And for that, I've always felt guilty. And there you have it. That's why I keep making this damn thing over and over again. Now can we quit?
如果你是在问我，而且我想你是想问，我对所发生的任何事情是否感到内疚？答案是肯定的。当然，我对某些事情感到内疚。我对自己把我和我的需求置于他人的需求、置于他的需求之上的行为感到内疚。我对此不够感激，也不够敏感。为此，我一直感到内疚。好了，这就是原因。这就是我为什么一次又一次地制作这该死的东西。现在我们可以结束了吗？
You know, you're the one who made these movies. You set yourself up for this whole chain of events here. So then, did you feel better after?
你知道，是你制作了这些电影。是你为这一整串事件搭建了舞台。那么，在那之后你感觉好点了吗？
Right now, I feel terrible. It's getting worse.
现在，我感觉糟透了。情况越来越糟。
Good, I think we're having a breakthrough here.
好，我想我们有了突破。
How about a cup to go?
来杯外带的怎么样？
The third version of the story, like the Sean Penn version, has a happy ending. Crispin Glover wears his Olivia Newton-John outfit out in public. He doesn't care what people think anymore, and then he literally drives off into the sunset. [MOTORCYCLE REVVING AND  MUSIC PLAYING]
故事的第三个版本，像肖恩·潘的版本一样，有一个圆满的结局。克里斯平·格洛弗公开穿着他的奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰服装。他不再在乎别人怎么想，然后他真的开车驶向了落日。（摩托车轰鸣声和音乐声）
The screen fades to black. When I saw this in the theater, everyone in the audience hesitated for a minute before standing up. We didn't know who might walk out onto that parking lot next.
屏幕淡入黑色。当我在电影院看到这一幕时，观众席上的每个人都迟疑了一分钟才站起来。我们不知道下一个谁会走出来走向那个停车场。
What's so crazy about Trent spending years making the exact same movie over and over, is not what he added to the film each time, but what he kept the same. Trent could've shot anywhere in the world, anything he wanted, but instead he kept coming back to the same drab parking lot. Details that would seem totally random to anyone watching, he repeats.
特伦特多年来一遍又一遍地制作完全一样的电影，最疯狂的地方不在于他每次在电影里增加了什么，而在于他保留了什么。特伦特本可以在世界上任何地方、拍任何他想拍的东西，但他却不断地回到同一个沉闷的停车场。对于任何观看的人来说，那些细节显得完全随机，但他却不断重复。
Like any obsession, it's always the most mundane things you can't shake. So what you end up with is a  series of movies that only make sense to the person who made them. The same story, over and over, with inexplicably happy endings thrown on. If I hadn't talked to Trent, I still would've loved these movies, but I would have had no idea what they were about. But that's OK. Because they weren't meant for us anyway.
像任何痴迷一样，你总是无法摆脱那些最平凡的事情。所以你最终得到的是一系列只有制作者本人才理解的电影。同样的故事，一遍又一遍，强加上了莫名其妙的圆满结局。如果我没有和特伦特谈过，我仍然会喜欢这些电影，但我会完全不知道它们是关于什么的。但这没关系。因为它们本来就不是给我们看的。
After Trent finished the last version of the film in 1985, he did the same thing that he'd done with the first two, absolutely nothing. 13 years later, he came across all three of them in his closet and hooked them together onto one reel for the first time. He screened it at a local theater in Utah. One thing led to another, and he was invited to screen it at the Sundance Film Festival. For the first time in 22 years, Trent had to find the Beaver Kid. He had a friend track him down to invite him to Sundance.
特伦特在1985年完成电影的最后一个版本后，做了他和前两个版本所做的一样的事情，什么都没做。13年后，他在壁橱里翻出了这三部电影，并第一次把它们接成了一盘磁带。他在犹他州的一家当地剧院进行了放映。事情就这样发生了，他被邀请在圣丹斯电影节上放映它。22年来，特伦特第一次不得不去找比弗男孩。他找了个朋友跟踪他，邀请他去圣丹斯。
So I mean, you've got to imagine this. You've got to take this into perspective. Is that he doesn't know. This happens in 1979 and in 2001 he gets a phone call that says this is going to play at the Sundance Film Festival. Well, just before the show starts, the tickets haven't been picked up. What happens is that we show the movie. It's a huge screening. There are 1,400 people there.
所以我是说，你必须想象一下这个场景。你必须客观看待它。他不知道。这一切发生在1979年，而在2001年他接到一个电话说这将在圣丹斯电影节播出。嗯，就在演出开始前，票还没被领走。结果是我们放映了电影。这是一场盛大的放映。有1400人在场。
And after the screening, there's a bunch of people run up to the stage and ask more questions, stuff like that. All of a sudden, out of this sea of faces, one emerges. And he says, you probably don't remember me. And I immediately recognized who he was. And I grabbed him and dragged him out the side door into a snow drift.
放映结束后，有一群人跑到舞台上问更多的问题，诸如此类的。突然，在这片人海中，一个人出现了。他说，你大概不记得我了。我立刻认出了他是谁。我抓住他，把他拖出侧门，拖进了雪堆里。
There was a lot of, huh, well, I mean, what have you-- well, I mean, wow-- That was really something. I can't believe. And then I'd say something like, yeah, I mean, wow, I tried to find you, but I didn't know where you were. And look at all this snow, and here comes a bunch of people. And then he'd say, oh my gosh, and I still have that car. And oh, you must think I'm some sort or a nut. And what in the heck is going on? Where all these people coming from? Do they think I'm some sort of a nut? Ans I said, No, no, everybody loves you, it's great. I mean, it was that kind of a conversation.
有很多，呃，好吧，我是说，你有什么——好吧，我是说，哇——那真是了不起。我简直不敢相信。然后我会说点什么，比如，是啊，我是说，哇，我试着找过你，但我不知道你在哪儿。看看这些雪，然后来了一群人。然后他会说，天哪，而且我还有那辆车。哦，你一定觉得我是个疯子。这到底是怎么回事？所有这些人从哪儿来的？他们觉得我是个疯子吗？我说，不，不，每个人都爱你，这很棒。我是说，那是那种谈话。
And then we're mobbed. All of the sudden, there's 50 people standing around taking pictures and asking for his autograph. He doen't know. He just starts signing autographs, and then kind of slipped right into it as if he'd been doing it for years.
然后我们被团团围住。突然，有50个人站在周围拍照，要他的签名。他不知道怎么回事。他只是开始签名，然后就像他已经做了多年一样顺其自然地融入了其中。
After the screening, I took him to the big Sundance party at the end of the festival. There is a huge, huge party under a big tent. The room's filled with movie stars and all kinds of glamorous people drinking champagne and having a heck of time. And nobody cared about the movie stars. They were all around him. They're asking him questions and getting his autograph. And beautiful women hanging on his arm and running off to get him a glass of beer. It was incredible. It was great. Literally, he was the biggest star in the room.
放映结束后，我带他去了电影节结束时的盛大圣丹斯派对。在大帐篷下有一个巨大的、巨大的派对。房间里挤满了电影明星和各种各样迷人的、喝着香槟、玩得极其开心的家伙。没人关心那些电影明星。他们都围着他。他们问他问题，要他的签名。漂亮的女人挽着他的胳膊，跑去给他拿啤酒。这真是太不可思议了。这太棒了。他简直就是房间里最大的明星。
So was it a relief?
那么这是一种解脱吗？
It was a tremendous relief for me.
对我来说这是一种巨大的解脱。
Trent kept remaking the same film because he wanted it to come out right. He wanted to give the kid a happy ending. And somehow, the plan worked. The Beaver Kid wanted to be a star. 22 years passed, and in the end, he was. And what happened in between doesn't have to make sense.
特伦特不停地重拍同一部电影，因为他想让它变得正确。他想给那个孩子一个圆满的结局。不知何故，计划成功了。比弗男孩想成为明星。22年过去了，最终，他确实成为了明星。而中间发生的事情不需要有任何逻辑。
Starlee Kine. Trent Harris's Beaver Trilogy is not in distribution. It's not available in stores. It will not be coming to a theater near you. And maybe it's not over yet.
斯塔莉·凯恩。特伦特·哈里斯的《海狸三部曲》并未发行。商店里买不到。它也不会在你附近的电影院上映。也许这一切还没结束。
He came up with an idea. He said, hey we ought to do part four. He had an idea, and I said, well, what's your idea? And he says, "Well, OK, imagine this. We're out on the sagebrush, nothing around except a long, long, dirt road. And you hear the music begin to creep up. And then over the horizon comes my car, in a cloud of dust, and I come. And I whip right up in front of the camera, and I screech to a halt. And as the dust clears, I lean out the window in my wig and I say, 'I ain't done yet.'" So we might do it this summer.
他想出了一个主意。他说，嘿，我们应该拍第四部。他有个想法，我说，好吧，你的想法是什么？他说：“好吧，想象一下。我们在灌木丛中，周围什么都没有，只有一条长长的土路。你听到音乐开始蔓延。然后在地平线上，我的车在一团尘土中出现，我来了。我猛地停在摄像机前，发出刺耳的刹车声。随着尘土散去，我戴着假发从窗户探出头说：‘我还没完呢。’”所以我们今年夏天可能会拍。
You might?
你们可能？
Of course I will. What? You have to film that. That sounds great.
当然会。什么？你必须拍下来。听起来很棒。
Coming up, sticking around after the break, is that a heroic act? A [? can do ?], starring the Montgomery Bus Boycott. We are pro and con-- well, mostly con actually. When we return in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，休息后，那是一种英雄行为吗？一场运动，主演是蒙哥马利公交车抵制运动。我们有赞成和反对——好吧，其实大多是反对。我们稍后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. If you're just tuning in today, we are talking about reruns, personal reruns. We've arrive at Act 2 of our program. Act Two, Marriage As Rerun. And let us begin this act with this scene of people stuck in personal reruns. A scene, I would bet, that you have probably been in yourself at one point or another.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。如果你刚刚收听，我们今天谈论的是重播，个人的重播。我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，婚姻如重播。让我们以这一幕中人们陷入个人重播的场景开始。我敢说，这个场景你自己在某个时候也可能经历过。
Carmen and Candido were out just the other night with a friend. And Carmen started telling a story about her nephew, Nikko.
卡门和坎迪多前几天晚上和一位朋友出去。卡门开始讲关于她侄子尼科的故事。
And as soon as I say, well, when Nikko was three years old, one Sunday. Candido rolls his eyes.
我刚说，嗯，尼科三岁的时候，有个周日。坎迪多就翻了个白眼。
See, the problem is, that I heard this story like 1,000 times. And I can't sit through it again. Carmen tells the story the exact same way all the time.
你看，问题是，这个故事我听了大概1000遍了。我没法再听下去了。卡门每次讲这个故事的方式完全一样。
Because it's very funny.
因为它非常有趣。
She should embellish it for me.
她应该为我润色一下。
Now, Candido, are there stories that you tell over and over?
那么，坎迪多，有没有你会一遍又一遍讲的故事？
No.
没有。
That's not true.
那不是真的。
I don't.
我没有。
That's so not true.
那太不真实了。
Yes friends, it is a fact of married life, one that is almost never discussed, that being married, being in any couple for more than one night, I would argue, means hearing the same stories over and over from your partner, possibly for the rest of your life. But have you noticed that of all the stories that could get told in front of each other, only certain stories do get told? Well, to understand the taxonomy of this, the ins and outs of this phenomenon, I spoke with three couples.
是的，朋友们，这是婚姻生活中的一个事实，几乎从不讨论。我认为，结婚，或者说在任何一对伴侣中待上超过一晚，就意味着你要一遍又一遍地听对方讲同样的故事，可能要伴随余生。但你有没有注意到，在所有可以互相讲述的故事中，只有某些故事才会被讲出来？嗯，为了了解这种现象的分类，了解这种现象的来龙去脉，我和三对夫妻聊了聊。
We begin with Carmen and Candido. There is a story that he tells about the day that he got hurt on the subway and strangers came to his aid. They live in New York City. And this story comes up in any conversation where it might be necessary to prove the point that New Yorkers are not cold hearted but, in fact, helpful and kind to each other. There are the stories that she tells about her nephew Nikko, which come up on when the topic of kids doing adorable things enters a conversation with her friends, usually with friends who have kids. And then there's the graduation story.
我们先从卡门和坎迪多开始。他讲过一个关于他在地铁受伤那天陌生人对他伸出援手的故事。他们住在纽约市。每当需要证明“纽约人并不冷漠，其实互相很有帮助和友善”这个观点时，这个故事就会出现。还有她讲的关于她侄子尼科的故事，每当她的朋友谈论孩子做的可爱事情时，通常是那些有孩子的朋友，这个故事就会出现。然后还有一个毕业典礼的故事。
Whenever they're talking about embarrassing moments, I guess this is the one that gets told a lot.
每当他们谈论尴尬时刻时，我想这是讲得最多的一个。
It comes up. Our mother's stories.
它会出现。我们的母亲的故事。
Our mother's story.
我们母亲的故事。
So should I tell my graduation story? Candido rolled his eyes.
那我要讲我的毕业故事吗？坎迪多翻了个白眼。
What happens in this story? Yeah, tell me the story.
这个故事里发生了什么？是的，讲给我听听。
OK, my mother was a teacher. She's now a principal. And she has that personality. Which is great. Very loving but very-- she's an Aries.
好吧，我妈妈是老师。她现在是校长。她有那种性格。这很好。非常有爱心但非常——她是白羊座。
Aggressive--
咄咄逼人——
So I went to Catholic school, and when I was graduating from eighth grade, we had our our graduation in the church, in the school's church. And [INAUDIBLE] of those Instamatic Kodak cameras. And she didn't advance the film when my name was called. And I went up there, and I received my diploma, and she didn't get a shot of that. So she goes, go back up there. I was like, mom, you are not making me go back up there.
所以我上的是教会学校，当我八年级毕业时，我们的毕业典礼在教堂里，在学校的教堂里举行。而且（听不清）那些柯达傻瓜相机。她在我名字被点到时没有推进胶片。我走上去领毕业证书时，她没拍到。所以她说，回去再走一遍。我当时想，妈，你不能让我回去再走一遍。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Yeah, completely. In the church, in front of everybody, go back up there right now. I was like, mommy, they're calling other people. And she said, "Father Bradley!" to the priest who was giving the diplomas out.
是啊，完全是。在教堂里，在所有人面前，现在就回去再走一遍。我当时想，妈咪，他们正在叫别人的名字呢。她说，“布拉德利神父！”冲着正在颁发毕业证书的神父喊。
Wait, she calls out from the audience?
等等，她从观众席上喊出来？
Well, she left her seat, and went up toward the altar. She's by the altar. And she goes, "Father Bradley, just hold on. Go back up there. Go back up there right now." Father Bradley posed, and she took the picture. And she goes, "OK, thank you. Oh, my baby!" And hugging me. Everybody is staring at me. And what I love about that moment, when I think about it, is that my mom didn't care what other people thought.
嗯，她离开座位，走向祭坛。她就在祭坛边上。她说，“布拉德利神父，等一下。回去再走一遍。现在就回去再走一遍。”布拉德利神父摆了个姿势，她拍了照片。她说，“好的，谢谢。哦，我的宝贝！”然后拥抱着我。每个人都在盯着我。关于那一刻，我想到时所热爱的是，我妈妈根本不在乎别人怎么想。
Exactly.
完全正确。
I've probably heard this story 20 or 25 times.
我大概听过这个故事20或25遍了。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN I would guess that she's probably heard it six to eight times.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 我猜她大概听过六到八遍。
It seems like a lot.
听起来很多。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN I think she thinks it's pretty funny.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 我想她觉得这挺有趣的。
This is our second couple, John and Catherine, who've known each other since high school. The story in question happened when they were both 21, both briefly living in England. It's a drinking story to be told while drinking about a night of drinking. John was the one who was drunk in the story. He was young. He was working lousy jobs. He was absolutely bored. So there was a lot of drinking in his life.
这是我们的第二对夫妻，约翰和凯瑟琳，他们从高中起就认识。所说的故事发生在他们21岁的时候，两人都在英国短期居住。这是一个在喝酒时讲的关于某个喝酒夜晚的喝酒故事。故事里喝醉的是约翰。他那时候很年轻。他做着烂工作。他非常无聊。所以他的生活中充满了喝酒。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN It was around this time that I also started doing some very low-key shoplifting. And I would take like a pack of gum, or like an onion. And this was very thrilling to me.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 大概就是在那个时候，我还开始做了一些非常小规模的商店行窃。我会拿一包口香糖，或者一个洋葱。这对我很刺激。
So one night John's friend Charles and another friend suggested they break into the London Zoo. Which at that time turned out to be surprisingly easy to do. They simply hopped over a low iron wrought fence. Once inside, they spotted a pool, with penguins sleeping all around it, right there behind a wall so low that you just step over it.
所以有一天晚上，约翰的朋友查尔斯和另一个朋友建议他们闯入伦敦动物园。当时事实证明那非常容易做到。他们只是跳过了一道低矮的铁栅栏。进入里面后，他们发现了一个池塘，企鹅们在周围睡觉，就在那面低矮的墙后面，你只需跨过去就行。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN Yeah, it was exciting, because I'd always liked penguins. I've now learned that they are kind of shifty and mean and also harbingers of doom. I simply stepped over the wall, and I walked down and walked up to a sleeping penguin. Apparently they are diurnal creatures, and they sleep at night. And this one was not very happy about being woken up, because I petted him a little, and he bit me on the finger. It was not a major wound, but it was a token of bad things to come.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 是的，这很令人兴奋，因为我一直很喜欢企鹅。我现在才知道它们其实有些狡猾而且刻薄，也是厄运的先兆。我只是跨过了那面墙，走过去走到一只睡觉的企鹅面前。显然它们是昼行生物，晚上睡觉。而这只对被吵醒很不高兴，因为我摸了它一下，它咬了我的手指。伤口不算严重，但这是未来不幸的象征。
I have to say, as a symbolic moment, it's a good one. Because something cute has suddenly become deeply un-cute.
我不得不说，作为象征性的时刻，这很棒。因为可爱的东西突然变得极不可爱了。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN You find penguins cute?
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 你觉得企鹅可爱？
What are you talking about? Everyone finds penguins cute.
你在说什么？每个人都觉得企鹅可爱。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN I look at them differently now.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 我现在以不同的眼光看它们了。
It would be like a teddy bear biting you or something.
这就像泰迪熊咬了你一样。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN Yeah, teddy bears are actually stuffed animals. But as an expert on penguin behavior, you're right, it is very unusual.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 是的，泰迪熊其实是填充玩具。但作为企鹅行为专家，你是对的，这确实非常不寻常。
What follows turns out to be one of those sprawling stories that takes 45 minutes to tell. So I will choose just a few highlights for you here. There is the run-in with the police. No story like this is complete without the run-in with the police. John is the only one caught. He's questioned. He's taken to jail. He does not tell them his real name. He does not rat out his friends. He tries to act tough with the cops.
接下来发生的事情是一连串要讲45分钟的长篇故事。所以我只为你选几个重点。这里有和警察的冲突。没有像这样的冲突，故事就不完整。约翰是唯一被抓住的。他被审问。他被带到监狱。他没有告诉他们他的真名。他没有出卖他的朋友。他试着在警察面前装硬汉。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN They were all laughing at me and saying, what were you doing? Are you Marlin Perkins or something? And they said, "OK, empty your pockets." Now, I had been smart in a way that I haven't been in a long time. Before we went to the zoo, I decided, somewhat presciently, that it would be a good idea for me to not have any identification with me. So I didn't bring my wallet or my keys or my ID.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 他们都在笑我，说，你在做什么？你是马林·珀金斯吗？他们说，“好吧，清空你的口袋。”现在，我以一种很久没这么做过的方式变得聪明了。去动物园之前，我决定，有点先见之明地认为，不带任何身份证件是个好主意。所以我没带钱包、钥匙或身份证。
But I did have an onion in my pocket. Which really kind of stopped everyone for a very long moment. It was the only thing that I had. And they said, "What is that for?" And I said, "To feed the animals?" And they seemed to enjoy that. And I kind of thought that this couldn't go on for much longer. But they decided to put me in a cell for a while.
但我口袋里有个洋葱。这确实让所有人在那一刻愣了很久。这是我身上唯一的东西。他们说，“那是干什么用的？”我说，“喂动物？”他们似乎很喜欢这个。我当时想这不可能再持续多久了。但他们决定把我关在牢房里一会儿。
An on and on, you get the idea. What's strikingly fascinating about hearing his wife, Catherine, tell this same story is that after hearing it at least 20 times-- Well, you'll hear.
就这样，你明白了吧。最引人入胜的一点是，当他的妻子凯瑟琳讲同一个故事时，在那至少听了20遍之后——嗯，你会听到的。
They had a good time for a while, and then, at some point, they were in the pig pen. And I don't know, they knew somehow that the police were there. Isn't funny that I am not really sure how this transpired?
他们玩了一会儿，然后，在某个时候，他们在猪圈里。我不确定，他们以某种方式知道警察在附近。不可笑吗，我其实不确定这是怎么发生的？
Do what animal bit John?
是什么动物咬了约翰？
A pig.
猪。
OK, that's not right.
好吧，那不对。
You're kidding?
你在开玩笑吗？
Nope, it's not a pig.
不，那不是猪。
I thought he was in the pig pen. And there's this whole thing where he's like, the pig is licking my ear.
我以为他在猪圈里。还有整个事情，他说，猪在舔我的耳朵。
Nope. Not the pig.
不。不是猪。
Was the pig licking Charles's ear?
是猪在舔查尔斯的耳朵吗？
You barely have this story. You barely know this story.
你几乎没记住这个故事。你几乎不知道这个故事。
I know. I do barely know this story. Do you think that I barely listen? Maybe I don't listen any more?
我知道。我确实几乎不知道这个故事。你觉得我几乎不听吗？也许我不再听了？
The part that she actually does remember every time she tells it is the part where he's in jail. She says it brings out some sort of maternal feeling in her. She just can't stand the thought of him going through that. What they're both clear on is why this is the story that John has told over and over for more than a decade. Here is John explaining.
每次她讲的时候，她真正记住的那部分是他被关在监狱里的那段。她说这激发了她内心的某种母性。她简直受不了他经历那一切的想法。他们都很清楚为什么这是约翰十多年来一遍又一遍讲的故事。这是约翰的解释。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN I think that the story, it's a version of myself that seems a little reckless, adventurous, quick-witted, but also ultimately humiliated by my own overreach.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 我认为这个故事，它是我的一个版本，看起来有点鲁莽、冒险、机智，但也最终因为自己的自负而蒙受羞辱。
Have you noticed that there's certain people that all the stories they tell, they are triumphant, and then other people, all the stories that they tell about themselves, they are humiliated.
你有没有注意到，有些人讲的所有故事都是他们胜利的，而另一些人讲的所有关于他们自己的故事，他们都是被羞辱的。
(SUBJECT) JOHN HODGMAN See, I think a good drinking story contains both. Both that heroic aspect and that completely de-clothed, humiliated, embarrassed aspect as well.
（采访对象）约翰·霍奇曼 瞧，我认为一个好的喝酒故事应该兼具两者。既有英雄的一面，也有完全赤裸、羞辱、尴尬的一面。
When I was talking to him about it, I asked him, why is this the story that gets told over and over? And he said, that a really good story like this should be something where the person telling the story both appears as a hero and then as an idiotic fool.
当我和他谈起这一点时，我问他，为什么这是那个一遍又一遍被讲的故事？他说，一个像这样的好故事应该让讲故事的人既看起来像英雄，又看起来像个白痴。
[LAUGHTER] Well, where's the hero part?
（笑）好吧，英雄的部分在哪儿？
Which brings us to our last couple, Robert and Tamar. They also have a story that gets repeated in their house that has been the source of a small difference in interpretation between them. It's a story they both tell. Though him more than her, you get feeling. They don't tell the story the same way. And we will start with her version of the story.
这就引出了我们的最后一对，罗伯特和塔玛。他们家里也有一个会被重复讲的故事，这成了他们之间解释存在小分歧的来源。这是他们俩都讲的故事。虽然他讲的比她多，你会有这种感觉。他们讲故事的方式不完全一样。我们将从她的版本开始。
The first thing you need to know about this story is that I am totally celebrity blind, just completely. So much of my life with Robert has been wandering around New York and him saying, oh, look you were sitting next to Candice Bergen. And I'd say, no I wasn't. And he's always right, and I'm always wrong. So I'm really pleased one day. I'm out all by myself in the world, and I'm on the East Side, and I'm walking down Madison Avenue. And I see someone, and I know-- me the celebrity blind person-- I know absolutely for sure, for sure that this person across the street is Jackie Kennedy. And not only is it Jackie Kennedy, but she's looking at me. And she has her hand up when I smile at her.
关于这个故事你需要知道的第一件事是我完全是脸盲，彻彻底底的。我和罗伯特的生活大部分时间都在纽约漫步，他会说，哦，看，你刚才坐在坎迪斯·伯根旁边。我会说，不，我没坐。而且他总是对的，我总是错的。所以有一天我真的很高兴。我独自一人在世界上，我在东区，我走在麦迪逊大道上。我看到一个人，我认识——我这个脸盲的人——我绝对确信，绝对确信街对面那个人是杰奎琳·肯尼迪。不仅是杰奎琳·肯尼迪，而且她在看我。当我向她微笑时，她举起了手。
OK, let's stop that right there. Before she gets too far, here is Robert's interpretation of the same event. Their interviews were recorded separately.
好吧，到此为止。在她走得太远之前，这是罗伯特对同一事件的解释。他们的采访是分开录制的。
It's a beautiful, beautiful fall day. And we're walking down Fifth Avenue. The Central Park is on our right. I just picture this very, very precisely. And we're walking along, and Tamar is distracted. She looks over her left shoulder, and she goes [SOUND OF SURPISE]. There I see, across the street, Jackie Onassis, President Kennedy's wife, and she's waving, very modestly, at Tamar.
这是一个美丽、美丽的秋天。我们走在第五大道上。中央公园在我们右边。我非常、非常准确地记得这个场景。我们走着走着，塔玛走神了。她转头看向左肩，然后发出（惊讶的声音）。在那里，我看到街对面是杰奎琳·奥纳西斯，肯尼迪总统的妻子，她正在非常谦虚地向塔玛挥手。
You've probably noticed the key differences already. He says that they're together. She says that she's alone. He says, next to Central Park. She says, Madison Avenue. But once she spots Jackie O, the stories fly in tandem for a while.
你可能已经注意到关键的区别了。他说他们在一起。她说她独自一人。他说靠近中央公园。她说麦迪逊大道。但一旦她发现了杰奎琳·O，故事就同步了一会儿。
She has her hand when I smile at her, and she waves at me.
当我向她微笑时，她举起了手，然后向我挥手。
And I thought, oh my God. I didn't know that they knew each other, whatever. And I'm looking at Tamar, and Tamar's looking at Jackie Onassis.
我想，哦，我的上帝。我不知道她们认识，不管怎样。我在看塔玛，塔玛在看杰奎琳·奥纳西斯。
And I'm so excited. And I wave back sort of tentatively, but beaming, beaming, beaming. And she waves back more so. I then wave back with my whole, whole heart.
我太兴奋了。我有点试探性地回挥，但光芒四射，光芒四射。她挥得更厉害了。然后我全心全意地回挥。
So I'm just staring at this in wonder. And then Jackie raises her hand even more excitedly and starts sort of moving it back and forth and back and forth.
所以我正惊奇地盯着这景象。然后杰奎琳更兴奋地举起手，开始来回摆动，来回摆动。
And I'm waving, and beaming, and I'm so happy and proud.
我在挥手，在发光，我感到如此快乐和骄傲。
And in that moment, a cab pulls up alongside Jackie Onassis. And what Jackie Onassis had actually been doing is just waving for a cab. And my wife, by mistake, somehow thought that Jackie was waving at her and is feeling really stupid.
就在那一刻，一辆出租车开到杰奎琳·奥纳西斯身边。而杰奎琳·奥纳西斯实际上所做的是仅仅是在打车。我妻子，出于误解，不知怎么以为杰奎琳是在向她挥手，感觉自己真的很蠢。
And so I'm really, pretty humiliated.
所以我真的，相当羞辱。
As am I.
我也是。
Because many people had been looking at Jackie Kennedy and many people had been looking at me making a fool of myself, waving, waving, waving, waving.
因为很多人一直在看着杰奎琳·肯尼迪，很多人一直在看着我出丑，挥手，挥手，挥手，挥手。
And so we laugh about it, and we head downtown.
所以我们对此笑了笑，然后前往市中心。
So we laugh about it, and we head downtown. Now that is where his version of the story ends, a moment of love, a moment of togetherness. Tamar's version of the story continues. In her version, she comes home. Remember, she experienced the whole thing alone in her version. She comes home, and she tells Robert what happened to her. Weeks later, in her version, they are at somebody's house for dinner, and Robert just launches into his version of the story, the version that you just heard.
所以我们对此笑了笑，然后前往市中心。好了，他的故事版本到这里结束了，这是爱的时刻，在一起的时刻。塔玛的故事版本还在继续。在她的版本中，她回到了家。记住，在这个版本中她独自经历了这一切。她回到家，告诉罗伯特在她身上发生了什么。几周后，在她的版本中，他们在某人家吃晚饭，罗伯特径直讲起了他的版本，就是你们刚才听到的那个版本。
As we leave that house, I say, you know Robert, you weren't there. And he said, "No. But I remember it, I can picture it, I can see it so clearly." And I say, "But you weren't there."
当我们离开那栋房子时，我说，你知道罗伯特，你当时不在场。他说，“不。但我记得它，我能想象它，我能看得那么清楚。”我说，“但你当时不在场。”
She says that I wasn't there. Which is astonishing to me. I mean, this is like I can feel this on my skin. I have told this story with such vividness because I remember it so vividly. I just remember things. Like things, like the way the sun was catching leaves. I remember turning around. I remember the intake of breath and the surprise. I remember all the little things going on in my mind . How do they know each other? Oh my God. She said, I wasn't there. I was never there. But she told it to me, and I, just simply, sort of like Ghengis Khan or Alexander the Great I occupied it. Like it was real estate that I wanted to be part of, so I just marched in and became part of it.
她说我当时不在场。这让我很震惊。我是说，这就像我能感觉到它在我皮肤上一样。我之所以把这个故事讲得如此生动，是因为我记得它如此生动。我只是记得事情。比如事情，比如太阳照在叶子上的方式。我记得转过身。我记得吸气声和惊喜。我记得我脑子里发生的所有小事。她们怎么认识？哦，我的上帝。她说，我当时不在场。我从没在场。但她告诉了我，我就，简直就像成吉思汗或亚历山大大帝一样，占领了它。就像我想成为一部分的房产，所以我直接走进去，成了它的一部分。
Do you believe her, that you weren't in it?
你相信她吗，你当时没在场？
Yeah. Yeah. Because I live, as all married people do, in a courthouse. And the jury, upon deliberating about this, said, this particular witness has proven over the years a complete-- and she is very, very believable. A credible witness has testified. And you sir? Over the years, we have formed our own opinions about you. Judgment to the wife.
是的。是的。因为我生活在一个法庭里，像所有已婚人士一样。陪审团在商议后说，这位特定的证人多年来证明了一个完全——而且她非常、非常可信。一位可信的证人作证了。那你呢，先生？多年来，我们对你也有了自己的看法。判决归妻子。
So now it's become a shared story.
所以现在它变成了一个共享的故事。
Wait, wait, and he'll tell it, and in his version, he's in the story?
等等，等等，他会讲这个故事，而在他的版本里，他在故事里？
In this version he has his view of what happened, but he says, but actually Tamar says I wasn't there.
在这个版本里，他对发生的事情有自己的看法，但他会说，但其实塔玛说我当时不在场。
Well thank you to all of our couple's, Carmen Rivera and Candido Tirado, John and Catherine Hodgman, and finally Tamar Lewin and Robert Krulwich.
好吧，谢谢我们所有的夫妻，卡门·里维拉和坎迪多·蒂拉多，约翰和凯瑟琳·霍奇曼，最后是塔玛·卢温和罗伯特·克鲁维奇。
Robert?
罗伯特？
Yeah.
是啊。
If the story about Jackie Kennedy is true, you be able to tell me what she was wearing.
如果关于杰奎琳·肯尼迪的故事是真的，你能告诉我她穿着什么吗？
Yeah, oh yeah. She was wearing a suit. She's wearing a suit, it had white buttons, and it had a collar, and it was a skirt, and I couldn't see her feet. But I remember that she had white buttons. You know where the buttons are attached to the garment, the stitching was black.
是啊，哦，是的。她穿着西装。她穿着西装，有白色纽扣，还有衣领，是裙装，我看不到她的脚。但我记得她有白色纽扣。你知道纽扣缝在衣服上的地方，缝线是黑色的。
OK, you were too far away to see that.
好吧，你离得太远了，看不到那个。
Yeah, exactly. I never stopped to wonder about the zoom lens that I apparently had handy at that time.
是啊，没错。我从没想过我当时随手拿到的那个变焦镜头。
[MUSIC - "FIVE TIMES OUT OF A HUNDRED" BY HOT HOT HEAT]
（音乐 - 热门热门热的《百分之五》）
Act 3, Reruns At The Back Of The Bus. But we are a nation that keeps re-running for ourselves a certain story about ourselves and about Rosa Parks. Not only ago there was even a small bit of controversy when the movie Barbershop chose to depart from the official fable that we usually tell ourselves. Well, Sarah Vowell has been watching the trend carefully wherever it appears.
第三幕，车尾的重播。但我们是一个不断为自己重播关于我们自己和罗莎·帕克斯的故事的国家。不久前，当电影《理发店》选择背离我们通常告诉自己的官方寓言时，甚至还引起了一点争议。嗯，莎拉·沃威尔一直在仔细观察这种趋势出现的地方。
According to Reuters, on January 20, 2001 in Washington DC, the special guest at the Florida State inaugural ball was introduced by the country singer Larry Gatlin. He said, in France it was Joan of Arc, in the Crimea it was Florence Nightingale, in the deep South there was Rosa Parks, in India there was Mother Teresa, and in Florida there was Katherine Harris. I leave it to my Indian, Crimean, and French colleagues to determine how the Florida Secretary of State is or is not similar to Teresa, Florence, or Saint Joan.
据路透社报道，2001年1月20日在华盛顿特区，佛罗里达州就职舞会的特别嘉宾由乡村歌手拉里·盖特林介绍。他说，在法国有圣女贞德，在克里米亚有弗罗伦斯·南丁格尔，在南方深处有罗莎·帕克斯，在印度有特蕾莎修女，在佛罗里达州有凯瑟琳·哈里斯。我留给我的印度、克里米亚和法国同事去决定佛罗里达州州务卿在多大程度上与特蕾莎、弗罗伦斯或圣女贞德相似。
As for Rosa Parks, Katherine Harris can get in line. Because people around here can't stop comparing themselves to Parks. To wit, the Mayor of Friendship Heights Maryland has proposed an outdoor smoking ban because, according to the Washington Post , citizens with asthma or other illnesses cannot have full access to areas where smokers are doing their evil deed. The mayor compares this horrific possibility to Rosa Parks being sent to the back of the bus.
至于罗莎·帕克斯，凯瑟琳·哈里斯可以排队了。因为这里的人无法停止把自己和帕克斯相提并论。据悉，马里兰州友谊高地的市长提议禁止户外吸烟，因为据《华盛顿邮报》报道，患有哮喘或其他疾病的公民无法完全进入吸烟者进行邪恶行为的区域。市长将这种可怕的可能性比作罗莎·帕克斯被送往公交车后排。
A California dairy farmer, protesting the government's milk pricing system, poured milk down a drain in front of TV cameras claiming that he had to take a stand just like Rosa Parks had to take a stand. A street performer in Saint Augustine, Florida is challenging a city ordinance that bans him from doing his act on the town's historic Saint George Street. The performers lawyer told the Florida Times-Union, telling these people they can exercise their first amendment rights somewhere other than on Saint George is like telling Rosa Parks that she has to sit in the back of the bus. Which is, coincidentally, also the argument of another Florida lawyer. This one representing adult dancers contesting Tampa's ordinance outlawing lap dancing.
一位加州奶农，为了抗议政府的牛奶定价系统，在电视摄像机前将牛奶倒入下水道，声称他必须像罗莎·帕克斯一样表明立场。佛罗里达州圣奥古斯丁的一位街头艺人正在挑战一项禁止他在该镇历史悠久的圣乔治街表演的城市法令。这位表演者的律师告诉《佛罗里达时代联盟》，告诉这些人他们可以在圣乔治街以外的地方行使第一修正案权利，就像告诉罗莎·帕克斯她必须坐在公交车后排一样。这巧合地也是另一位佛罗里达州律师的论点。这位律师代表挑战坦帕市取缔膝上舞法令的成人舞者。
I would also like to mention the rocker, marksman, and conservative activist Ted Nugent who, in his autobiography, God , Guns, and Rock and Roll , refers to himself as Rosa Parks with a loud guitar. Which is so inaccurate. Everyone knows he's more like Mary Matalin with a fancy deer rifle.
我还想提一下摇滚歌手、射击手和保守派活动家泰德·纽金特，他在自传《上帝、枪支和摇滚》中称自己为“带着响亮吉他的罗莎·帕克斯”。这太不准确了。大家都知道他更像带着一把花哨猎枪的玛丽·马塔林。
Call me picky, but breathing secondhand smoke, being subject to unfair dairy pricing, and not being able to mime or lap dance, though they are all tragic, tragic injustices, are not quite as bad as the systematic segregation of public transportation based on skin color.
别说我挑剔，呼吸二手烟，遭受不公平的牛奶定价，以及不能模仿或跳膝上舞，尽管这些都是悲剧，是悲剧性的不公正，但它们并不像基于肤色的公共交通系统性隔离那样糟糕。
And while fighting for your right to lap dance and mime, and breathe just the regular pollution and not the cigarette smokers, is a very fine, very American idea, it is not quite as brave as being a middle-aged black woman in Alabama in 1955 telling a white man she's not giving him her seat despite the fact that the law requires her to do so. And oh, by the way, in the process, she gets arrested. And then sparks the Montgomery Bus Boycott, which is the seed of the Civil Rights Movement as we know it. The Bus Boycotters not only introduced a 26-year-old pastor by the name of Martin Luther King junior into national public life, but after many months of car pools, walking, and court fights against bus segregation, got the separate-but-equal doctrine declared illegal once and for all.
虽然为了你有权跳膝上舞和模仿，以及呼吸正常的空气而不是香烟烟雾而奋斗是一个非常棒、非常美国式的想法，但它并不像1955年阿拉巴马州一位中年黑人妇女告诉白人她不会给他让座，尽管法律要求她这样做那样勇敢。哦，顺便说一下，在此过程中，她被捕了。然后引发了蒙哥马利公交车抵制运动，这是我们所知的民权运动的种子。公交车抵制者不仅将一位名叫马丁·路德·金二世的26岁牧师引入了国家公共生活，而且经过数月的拼车、步行和反对公交车隔离的法律斗争，最终使“隔离但平等”的原则被永久宣布为非法。
It's not just the people on the right, like Katherine Harris and Ted Nugent, who seem especially silly being likened to Parks. I first cringed at this analogy trend at the lefty Ralph Nader's October 2000 campaign rally in Madison Square Garden. Ever sit in a coliseum full of people who think they're heroes? I was surrounded by thousands of well meaning well fed white kids who loved it when the filmmaker Michael Moore told them they should, like Rosa Parks, stand up to power.
不仅仅是右派人士，如凯瑟琳·哈里斯和泰德·纽金特，把自己比作帕克斯显得特别愚蠢。我第一次对这种类比趋势感到畏缩是在拉尔夫·纳德2000年10月在麦迪逊广场花园的竞选集会上。有没有坐进过充满以为自己是英雄的人的竞技场？我被成千上万心地善良、吃得饱饱的白人孩子包围着，当电影制作人迈克尔·摩尔告诉他们应该像罗莎·帕克斯一样勇敢面对强权时，他们喜欢极了。
: What if Rosa Parks had said to herself, I'm the only person on this bus, I can't win? I'm afraid.
：如果罗莎·帕克斯当时对自己说，我是这辆车上唯一的人，我赢不了？我很害怕，那会怎么样？
By which I think he meant, vote for Nader so he could qualify for federal matching funds. I think I'm a fine enough person. By the very next morning I was having people over for waffles. But I hope I'm not being falsely modest by pointing out that I'm no Harriet Tubman and I'm certainly no Rosa Parks. As far as I'm concerned, about the only person in recent memory who has an unimpeachable right to compare himself to Parks is that Chinese student who stared down those tanks in Tiananmen Square.
我想他的意思是，投票给纳德，这样他就能获得联邦匹配基金。我觉得我是一个足够好的人。第二天早上我还请人吃华夫饼。但我希望我没有通过指出我不是哈里特·塔布曼，当然也不是罗莎·帕克斯而表现得过于谦虚。就我而言，记忆中最近唯一一个有无可争辩的权利把自己比作帕克斯的人，是那个站在天安门广场面对坦克群的中国学生。
I was reminded of those Naderites watching a rerun of the sitcom Sports Night on Comedy Central . Dan, a television sportscaster played by Josh Charles, has been ordered by his network to make an on-air apology to viewers because he said in a magazine interview that he supports the legalization of marijuana. He stands by his opinion and balks at apologizing. His boss, Isaac, played by Robert Guillaume, agrees but tells him to do it anyway.
看着喜剧中心频道的喜剧片《体育之夜》的重播，我想起了那些纳德的支持者。由乔什·查尔斯饰演的丹是一名电视体育评论员，被网络要求向观众进行电视道歉，因为他在杂志采访中表示支持大麻合法化。他坚持自己的观点，拒绝道歉。由罗伯特·吉劳姆饰演的老板艾萨克同意这一点，但让他无论如何都要这么做。
Because this is television and this is how it's done.
因为这是电视，这就是它的运作方式。
Yeah, well, sitting in the back of the bus was how it was done until a 42-year-old lady moved up front. I'm not very impressed with how things are done, Isaac.
是的，好吧，坐在公交车后排也是它的运作方式，直到一位42岁的女士搬到了前排。我对事情的运作方式印象不深，艾萨克。
A few minutes later Isaac looks Dan in the eye and tells him--
几分钟后，艾萨克注视着丹的眼睛告诉他——
Danny, you know I love you, don't you?
丹尼，你知道我爱你，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
And because I love you, I can say this. No rich young white guy has ever gotten anywhere with me comparing himself to Rosa Parks. Got it?
因为我爱你，所以我可以说这个。没有哪个富有的年轻白人因为把自己比作罗莎·帕克斯而对我有什么意义。懂吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
Good.
很好。
Finally, the voice of reason. Which, of course, was heard on a canceled network TV series airing on cable. Analogies give order to the world and solidarity. Pointing out how one person is like another is reassuring, less lonely. Maybe those who would compare their personal inconveniences to the epic struggles of history are just looking for company. And who wouldn't want to be in the company of Rosa Parks. On the other hand, perhaps people who compare themselves to Rosa Parks are simply arrogant, pampered nincompoops with delusions of grandeur who couldn't tell the difference between a paper cut and decapitation.
终于，理性之声出现了。当然，这是在有线电视上播出的被取消的网络电视系列节目中听到的。类比赋予世界秩序和团结。指出一个人如何像另一个人是令人安心的，不那么孤独。也许那些将个人不便与历史的史诗斗争相提并论的人只是在寻找同伴。谁不想和罗莎·帕克斯为伍呢？另一方面，也许那些把自己比作罗莎·帕克斯的人只不过是傲慢、宠坏、有着宏大妄想，连纸割伤和斩首区别都分不清的傻瓜。
In defense of Ted Nugent, the street performer, the mayor, the dairy farmer, the lap dancers, the Naderites, and a fictional sportscaster, I will point out that Katherine Harris is the only person on my list of people lamely compared to a civil rights icon who, at the very moment she was being compared to a civil rights icon, was actually being sued for massive voter disenfranchisement of people of color during the presidential election by the NAACP.
为了给泰德·纽金特、街头艺人、市长、奶农、膝上舞者、纳德的支持者和一位虚构的体育评论员辩护，我会指出凯瑟琳·哈里斯是我名单上所有被拙劣地比作民权偶像的人中，唯一一个在被比作民权偶像的时刻，正因为在总统选举期间大规模剥夺有色人种选民权利而被全国有色人种协进会起诉的人。
[MUSIC - "ROSA PARKS" BY OUTKAST]
（音乐 - 痞子阿里的《罗莎·帕克斯》）
Sarah Vowell is the author of the book, The Partly Cloudy Patriot , where her thoughts about Rosa Parks appear.
莎拉·沃威尔是《多云的爱国者》一书的作者，她关于罗莎·帕克斯的思考出现在书中。
Well, our program is produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, David Kastenbaum, and Starlee Kine. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Music help from Agoraphone. Special thanks today to Jeffrey Brown, author of the comic book Clumsy . Thanks to Jamie York and Doug Stone. The song, Could Be Worse had lyrics by Sarah Vowell and music by They Might Be Giants and featured Robin Goldwasser. It is not collected on the new They Might Be Giants CD-DVD set, Venue Songs .
好吧，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、温迪·多尔、大卫·卡斯滕鲍姆和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。音乐帮助来自Agoraphone。今天特别感谢杰弗里·布朗，漫画书《笨拙》的作者。感谢杰米·约克和道格·斯通。歌曲《情况可能更糟》由莎拉·沃威尔作词，他们可能是巨人乐队作曲，并由罗宾·戈德瓦瑟演唱。它没有被收录在新的“他们可能是巨人”CD-DVD套装《场地歌曲》中。
Our website, where you can get the free weekly podcasts, it's free, of our program. Where we do your Christmas shopping, send our brand new greatest hits double CD set, Stories Of Hope And Fear to someone you love-- www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获得免费的每周播客，是免费的，我们的节目。在那里我们为你代购圣诞礼物，发送我们全新的热门歌曲双CD套装，《希望与恐惧的故事》给你爱的人——www.thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金资助说明）
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia. He's been working on his John Wayne imitation, waiting for his big break, really. Here, listen.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。他一直在练习他的约翰·韦恩模仿，等待他的大突破，真的。来，听听。
Well, let me tell you, something out there in TV land, I just made the tube, and it just tickles the heck right out of me.
好吧，让我告诉你们，电视机前的各位，我刚上了电视，这真是让我高兴得不得了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI Public Radio International
PRI 公共广播国际公司